and largely, the etiquettes
speaking and what is
appropriate, what is
inappropriate, what is
permissible for a person to
say, what type of thing did the
prophet discourage when it
comes to things that people
say, sayings, proverbs, idioms,
beliefs that people have,
etcetera. All of this has been
discussed in depth in the past
few chapters and we've taken a
lot of extra time in these
chapters in order to articulate
the spirit of what Ibn Rahim
Allah intended with regards to
these chapters.
we discussed
in our previous class
we discussed etiquettes of
asking the people of knowledge
and the etiquettes of the
people of knowledge in their
speech and in their
We mentioned for instance, that
Ibn Rahim
says that it is
[Silence]
that for the person who is
speaking, teaching,
disseminating knowledge of the
book of Allah, of the of the
prophet when a person says,
Allah
permitted such and such or
Allah has prohibited such and
such. This is only when things
are clear. crystal clear,
totally unambiguous, and what
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
said regarding that issue.
However, when it comes to the
issues of
much of the argument can be
conjecture Much of the argument
is what is referred to as
meaning that the scholar who
makes this who formulates this
opinion while this opinion
finds its roots in the Quran
and Sunnah. The actual
statement, the actual issue is
not explicitly
explicitly mentioned in the way
that the person says it's halal
or haram. A person would not
say, Allah has made this haram.
Unless we have clear evidence
of that. Allah has made this
halal. Unless we have clear
evidence of that. But in issues
of whereas we said, it is a it
is an opinion formulated by a
scholar. It finds its roots in
the Quran and Sunna. This is
something where the Mufti
should say it in a particular
way. Say the the correct
opinion is such and such. Or I
lean more towards this. Or this
is what we should do. If it's
an issue. Rather than Allah
said or the prophet said
because there this is an
opinion that has been
formulated by a man. And it
could be incorrect and that
should not be ascribed
explicitly to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala or his messenger.
He says
[Silence]
to discuss
what happens in private behind
closed doors between a husband
and wife to discuss this thing
outside with other people. This
of course is haram and this is
the attributes of of people who
are very uneducated and very
morally corrupt and bankrupt.
this is the this is kind of
the actions of the riff raft.
People that don't really mind
that others see their wives or
see their husbands in that
light. A person should never
speak about intimacy and
generally or explicitly of that
which goes on between himself
And his wife. Not in the
abstract and not in any
specific way. He says
he says another thing that is
prohibited for a person to
speak. What he means by
prohibited. What he means by
something that is not correct
to say. He's speaking about the
spirit. The actual attitude
that is behind these words. So
he mentions here they say they
claim it's been said, right?
Whatever follows something like
that, it's been said, they say,
Usually, this is something what
follows that is not going to be
a beneficial fact. Usually,
it's going to be a statement of
pure conjecture at at many
times. It is not good for a
person to constantly be
repeating everything that he
says. There is a narration and
it's also the words of and
Abdullah. Muslim Allah
mentions this and ascribes it
to Omar and Ibn Masood and the
introduction of his that they
said
and your
it is enough for a person to
repeat everything they've
heard. That's enough falsehood
that will come from that
person. What this means is that
what what you hear, there's
good and there's bad. A person
should not just say everything
that they've heard. They should
vet what they hear and only say
that which is beneficial. If it
is something that is
detrimental, something that is
bad, something that is
conjecture, something that is
uncertain. A person should not
repeat these things Because in
repeating these things, a
person will inevitably start to
repeat rumors, start to repeat
gossip, lies, half truths,
etcetera. And so a person must
vet what they hear before they
speak of it.
He says
But in the
[Silence]
to not allow these things to be
very constant in his words.
I've done this, I've done that,
I have this, I have that,
right? This kind of selfishness
and self-centeredness is very
dangerous and Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala he warns us of the
danger of this attitude. For
instance, in Belize is one to
have said, I am better than he
is. And to me belongs the
treasures and the dominion of
Egypt. And for Karun, I have
been given this tremendous
wealth because of a knowledge
that I have, that I possess.
This is a warning from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to not
allow these prono and what
follows them to be a center
focus in a person's mind and
especially in a person's
speech. Human beings naturally
have a disposition against
arrogance, against haughtiness,
Men
the
[Silence]
of the prophet Allah is now
going to relate to us very
eloquently and rather is going
to relate to us the biography
of the prophet and the history
of Islam. Now, when we look at
the first section of Zad al
Maad, the first and second
sections they were about the
five pillars of Islam and
etiquettes and so forth. This
third section here is the
section on the prophet
biography. And the occurrences
that transpired in his time
until his death. The fourth
portion of this book is
regarding medicine prophetic
cures and remedies. And the
fifth section of Zad Al Maad is
all about the prophet
judgement. All of his
judgments, the things that he
the rulings that he made and so
forth and disputes and
otherwise. So, we've gone into
the third section. Now, as we
said before, is a really huge
book. It's huge. And very
dense, very deep, and I believe
it's it's quite an achievement
that we have arrived now at the
third portion of this wonderful
book.
Ya He said, this chapter is
regarding the prophet
in his travels, in his
campaigns, military campaigns,
and so forth.
He says,
[Silence]
and preach to Islam. Of course,
we mentioned before that there
are stages in the Dawah. The
stages were at first. It was
the prophet and just the very
few people around him, his
wife, etcetera. Then, we a more
discrete stage of Dawah where
it was himself and those around
him and his larger family and
tribesmen. Then after this, we
had open Dawah where he began
to give Dawah to everyone. It
was a public affair to all of
Mecca and anyone that would
come to Mecca in the different
various tribes. Then, the
prophet migrated to Medina and
there was another stage of
Dawah they're in. So when the
prophet began to call to Islam
and call to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and the worship of
Allah. people from each tribe
of the tribes the Arab tribes,
and the Qurashi tribes and the
outskirts of Quraish and so
forth and the Meccan tribes.
People from everyone of those
tribes started to answer the
call and become Muslim and
enter into Islam. The person at
the foremost of those who
answered the prophet call and
responded to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala was Abu Bakr Sudiq. And
so Abu
kind of joined his resources
with the prophet and he sought
to protect him, to fund him,
and to help him in any way that
was necessary. And so Abu Bakr
began to call to Allah and
invite to Islam as well. With
the prophet and some most
notable of the comp who became
Muslim as a result of Abu Bakr
Suddiq's Dawah to them and
invitation was and and also
sad. So we see that three of
the ten people earmarked for
paradise. All of them three of
them became Muslim as a result
as a direct result of Abu Bakr
inviting them to Islam.
Khadijah.
the
[Silence]
maintained her support for the
prophet in his Dawah. And when
the prophet said to her, I
honestly was very afraid. I
feared for myself. When he had
the first encounter with
Jibreel, very well-known
narration and story and Mount
Herah when Jibreel came to him
there in the cave and and
delivered the first five verses
of Surat.
of he returned very scared and
in shock and he explained to
Khadijah what had happened and
he told Khadijah I honestly
feared for myself. I was afraid
that this was some kind of
punishment. and so Khadijah did
not waver at all and she said
no. Allah would never put
someone you to shame. And
then she mentioned many of his
traits. That no two people
could disagree were traits of
were very dignified traits were
traits of the righteous and the
dutiful. That he was good to
his guest and that he kept
strong ties with his kin and
his family, that he was good to
the poor, he was aiding and
helpful to those less less
fortunate than himself He says,
and
[Silence]
she later was given. Of those
merits is that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala sent to her a
salutation of a salaam. from
Jibreel to Muhammad to her.
She's the same chain of
narration. Of the Quran. And so
she's referring to a narration
in Sahih Al Bukhari. In which
Hadi
was tending to the prophet and
she approached him while he was
actually speaking with Jibreel
and Jibreel said to him,
Khadijah is coming and convey
to her from her lord Assalam.
And so, the prophet conveyed
this salaam. That Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala conveys a
salaam to you. Islam
Ibn sinin. Akhil Akht
[Silence]
that and he accepted Islam at 8
years old and he happened to be
in the in the household of the
prophet they had a hard year.
They had hard year and food was
scarce. Resources were scarce.
And so had actually was
spending time and being raised
by the prophet Muhammad in his
household. because he took
on the the responsibilities of
caring for as a child. Because
of a time of of need and and
poverty. that had passed
through the home of Abu Talib,
his uncle.
So, He said, and another who,
ad hastened to accept Islam was
and he was actually a servant
who was owned by Khadijah and
Khadijah
then thus became his master and
his owner and the prophet freed
him and adopted him as his own,
his own son. So, it's it would
be referred to as Mohammed. He
says,
A and so, one day, his father
and his uncle show up to come
and purchase his freedom. You
might say, well, how does
Zaidab and Hadith end up as a
slave if his father and uncle
are coming looking for him? You
know, slavery in the time of
pre-Islamic Arabs Slavery was a
very common occurrence. Person
could become a slave literally
overnight. People became slaves
in many different ways. Either
they were
sold. A person would sell his
children because of poverty or
need. Person may sell his
children. A person may owe a
debt. And give one of his
children as as up as as that
debt. It's And so, Zaidab and
Haritha, this had happened to
him. How he came to be owned by
Khadijah is unclear, but his
father and his uncle, later
were able to pay that debt, so
they came to free, and
purchased the freedom of Zaidab
and Harita. And so when he
came, the prophet had already
freed him and adopted him as
his own. And when they came,
the prophet said,
for
[Silence]
for the and so they came to
forcefully take him. Like,
look, we have the purchase, we
want to take him now. And he
said, look, I'll, I'll meet you
in the middle. I can't force
him to go anywhere. But I'll
give him a choice. And if he
chooses to go with you, then
I'll let him go. No problem. So
they said, that is a reasonable
compromise. So, the prophet
called Zaid and he gave him, he
gave him a choice.
Call away hack. Yazaid, Liz
Aidwei, Hakia Zaid.
[Silence]
And so, they said, how could
you choose to be a slave in
this man's house rather than
over your father and your
uncle, your own family? He
said, I have witnessed things
from this man that forced me,
meaning of his kindness and
generosity and his etiquette
and his character, etcetera
which is mira in itself which
caused me to arrive to the
conclusion that I would never
choose to live in anyone's
house or at anyone's service or
care other than he and so when
the prophet heard this from
Zaeed, he took him to another
room, took him aside to his
family, to his wife, and he
said, I hereby announce to you
that Zaid is now officially my
son. I will inherit from him
and he from me. This is what's
called adoption at that time
and this was before Revelation.
And so the prophet didn't want
to keep Zaid as a slave after
he chose him over his own
family. And so he freed him at
that point. He emancipated him.
And he took him on as his own
son. He adopted him. And so his
father and his uncle found that
that was very reasonable. That
at least if he's not if he's
not coming with us, he will be
an adopted son of such a good
man. Wadua, Za Mohammed Islam.
Vanessalet, Ud him
and so Zaid would be referred
to as Zaid, son of Muhammad.
And then revelation came and in
Medina the verses of were
revealed in which Allah
wrecked and just in the sight
of Allah and in the estimate of
Allah.
And so after this was revealed.
He was referred to as Zad ab
and Haritha because Harita is
his biological father's name.
And Maamar narrates the said
Mamer narrates the a Zur he
said Zaid is the first person
that we know to have become
Muslim. First here is relative.
Meaning, the first person from
amongst the servants to become
Muslim. So, you're going to
find narrations that say, Zaid
is the first Muslim. You'll
find narrations that say, Abu
Bakr was the first Muslim. Good
to find narrations that say,
Khadijah was the first Muslim.
Other narrations that say, Ali
was the first Muslim. This is
all relative, right? So, Abu
Bakr was the first of free men,
adults, and Khadijah, the first
of the women, and Ali the first
of the youth. And Zaid, the
first of, the servants. So,
this is a relative firstness,
but the first first person had
become Muslim except Islam was
Khadijah,
and so, this was a great This
was a great honor that Zaid had
to be called Zaid, son of
Muhammad, right? To have the
prophet Muhammad in his lineage
that. But that was taken
away from him, right? And at no
and due to no or or wrong in
his part. So the scholars
mention of the and his that
Allah Subhanahu wa ta'ala took
away from Zaid something and
replaced it with something
better. So, he took away from
Zaid that he would be called
Zaidab and Mohammed. After
that, he was to be referred to
as but instead, he placed his
name in the Quran and so Zaid
is the only name of any
companion who's explicitly
mentioned in the Quran.
Muhammad was